[Music]
hello viewer happy fourth you may say
Independence Day I say fourth I don't
know why I was raised in Canada so this
next installment I didn't learn a whole
lot about and by not a whole lot I mean
none at all
we spent an entire semester on how we
burned down the White House before
actually Canada was really a country was
technically still a colony the point is
the civil war is more interesting
we have David Barton of wall builders
here and we'll be doing an installment
today on the civil war and maybe some of
the most common misconceptions before it
thank you for having us
sure man good to have you here this is a
civil war drum it is a civil war drum it
is is this a civil war camera that goes
back to that time this is a kind of
camera they used from Civil War days
going into the 1920s and 30s so it would
have been the kind of stuff that Brady
would have used later to take pictures
famous pictures Civil War I should put
that on Etsy yeah that's exactly
probably just think oh that's quaint
that looks almost looks original and you
have a lot of artifacts here from the
Civil War I guess let's sort of kind of
walk people through the civil a lot of
folks say and you hear this argued a lot
the Civil War really didn't have
anything to do with slavery right it was
about economics was about states rights
and that's kind of we look back on it
more fondly thing was about freeing the
slaves is that accurate
well I I kind of like let the document
speak for themselves and so when you
look at the Civil War you had 11 states
that seceded to become the Confederate
States of America
and so these 11 states when they left
the United States they all wrote a
document of secession on why they left
and they and by the way all of their
congressmen from those states gave
farewell addresses on the floor of the
House and Senate that are public record
anybody can get them Constitution
requires just to keep records of every
speech made so that's public record out
there so if you take the secession
documents of the 11 states telling the
world why we did what we did every one
of them says it's because of slavery
every one of them really now that's the
southern documents that's not a
northerner or anybody else and you know
I'm from the south but that's not
anybody else saying oh you guys made it
about slavery they're the ones who said
that without exception all
and said slavers issue now you could say
well it was economics that's true but
the backbone of your economy was slavery
right and so that that was economics but
you yourself in your secession document
you're the one who said that we left
because he's trying to end slavery it's
interesting we often hear the civil wars
about states rights and the federal
government's trying to tell the southern
states what to do right and as and as
Federalists as conservatives that's an
argument that would appeal to us to a
degree and so we think that it was all
about states rights which is interesting
that in the Confederate Constitution to
be a member of the Confederate States of
America you are not allowed to end
slavery you had to maintain slavery
that's part of the cost so if it's all
about states rights what are you doing
enjoining a group that won't let you
have the right to decide what to do with
that issue so it was it really was about
slavery and that's made by their
constitution their vice providing pot
they were had a little time that was
really bad yeah that was a big issue
back there that Missouri really big well
you know that's a border state it's
really the deep southern stays like
Alabama and all those states yeah there
yeah right yeah so they they really had
this thing of slavery was the issue
according to them according to their
political platforms according to their
own constitutions and according to their
secession document what about according
to we have this pick I can touch this
because I feel comfortable because it's
very laminated according to this man
Abraham Lincoln if he could have kept
the Union without ending slavery and a
lot of people say that that's that's
what he would have done he felt that it
was an asset so what do you've done that
he would have kept slavery well I say
that the whole argument all the way up
to that by the way looks a lot more
ethnic than usually think of Abraham
Lincoln when you look at that I mean he
could be Native American he could be I
don't know he could be you Ukranian it
was Becca's dannion yeah the point is
it's not Daniel day-lewis from okay his
nut so with Lincoln are leading up to
all those years before the Civil War
with the abolition debates there was no
clear consensus that the Constitution
prohibited slavery that pretty much left
at each state right now the founding
fathers they thought when they were
doing the Constitution who mentioned
they all agreed if you give us 20 years
we're going to in slavery
which is why they put the data 1808 so
20 years after the Constitution written
they thought they could give her slavery
they can ban the slave trade and be done
with it
even the pro-slavery states and why did
they want to do that who would you would
be included in those founding fathers
who wanted to end slavery and well it's
interesting that when we did the
Declaration of Independence the longest
single grievance in the Declaration was
written by Thomas Jefferson and he said
we have been trying to end slavery in
America and the king won't let us
because in 1773 you had Rhode Island and
you had Massachusetts and Connecticut
you you had Pennsylvania all do
anti-slavery laws and in 1774 the king
said no no no you're part of the British
Empire
we have slavery you're going to have
slavery so at that point founding
fathers like Ben Franklin and Benjamin
Rush and others said this is not right
we've been trying to free our own slaves
he won't even we don't like slavery we
don't want it and so you'll find that 41
of the signers and declaration owned
slaves it's not a question of how many
own slaves what did they do once they
had the right to in slavery so when we
separated 1776 you'll find that so many
of this guy's freed slaves said this
would have been waiting for this is why
we want to separate from Great Britain
and so that largest grievance in the
Declaration is Thomas Jefferson saying
we've been trying to end slavery and
they won't let us Jefferson had been
introducing anti-slavery laws in his own
state his state would not allow him to
free his own slaves right not just the
British but his States so what happened
was was it with a Jefferson who or was
it Washington who freed them at the time
of his Washington freedom of time his
death there was a loophole in the law
that was added in 1782 to Virginia law
that says okay we want people to be free
so when you die you can free but even
when with that even when you die you can
free your slaves they never allowed you
to free what were called dowry slaves
and dowry slaves were the slaves that
came through the wife so Martha's slaves
George Washington he can't free Martha's
slaves you can never free a down rich
slave so Jefferson by the time he came
to Jefferson the the legislature said
what were we thinking about that was a
bad loophole so they closed the loophole
he didn't even have that loophole at the
time of his death so what happened was
Jefferson wrote this anti-slavery piece
in the Declaration and he wrote because
the Declaration says the unanimous
declaration they all agreed that the
only thing we'll put in
declaration is what all 13 states agree
on Jefferson said South Carolina and
North Carolina and Georgia would not
agree this slavery was a big issue and
so we had to take that clause out right
so the Civil War was a long time brewing
it didn't just come out of nowhere like
a lot of people think but those three
states thought that if you give us 20
years we can be away from slavery and
they probably would have been because
slavery is economically unprofitable
right well kept it alive was 1803 the
cotton gin comes in and now slave can do
what ten slaves used to do so now I can
make money so it changed the whole
economy slave economy changed but there
was the belief 2x8 you know wait we can
get this done in America so and before
we move what are these here I see some
these are all Civil War oh and by the
way sorry I should have said this is
actually the picture that was used right
that they use that's what they used to
build the Lincoln Memorial that is the
picture that was used for that and this
is the negative that was used for that
picture the photo negative Abraham
Lincoln now you're looking at what
looked at Lincoln essentially so that so
all of this so all that to say that at
the time of Lincoln slavery was not a
settled constitutional issue right
because the Constitution did mana so his
job is to take an oath to uphold the
Constitution which he would have done
that if slavery had to be required he
hated it he he was against it he spoke
against it but when it became clear
after the split that I can't save the
Union without ending slavery then that's
where he went okay and he did that with
this I assumed
well this yeah actually by the way is
that maybe a little short for you as a
crutch it's a man yeah it almost as a
belt height this came from a black
soldier and this is a crutch this is a
crutch that was a black soldier in Civil
War it seems like he's pretty tall oh
the way it's a crunch I think Cain never
mind
oh wow that was tiny tiny too by the way
that was [ __ ] too while we're there
it's a far cry from Wilt Chamberlain you
would not he would not have been the guy
out of the basketball team
he wouldn't it was a Canadian guy
invented Baskin well while we're there I
want to introduce you to a guy a very
famous guy in a in in civil war his name
is John Klem okay John clam for bravery
at the battle Chickamauga newspaper
reported that for what he did in that
battle
his bravery is so great that Lieutenant
Rosecrans saw his bravery on the
battlefield and promoted him on the spot
from being a private to being a sergeant
well and then general Thomas came in and
said no no I need you on my staff and
made him a lieutenant and put him on his
staff on the General Staff he's 12 years
old what this that is the soldier so
that's his that's not no no this is a
black guy but I want you to see how
small it's hard to tell with the photo
negatives and the nine is black and
white I couldn't really see okay no
that's clearly a white 12 it's a whi 12
year old I don't see color here is as
you don't see color I'm colorblind
we're all the human race oh there you go
nice job so this is him too so you see
how smart that's his soldiers that is
his sergeants uniform Wow he's about
this tall and so I mean they were small
really small back then yeah he was
smaller than usual they were all pretty
small so this is this is from the mass
54th the movie glory yeah this is one of
the soldiers that was featured and would
have been featured in that movie
glorious the Matthew Broderick probably
could have actually used that he
probably could he's about the right
heard that so that that is from the
Civil War this is a hand grenade from
the Civil War what you do load it up
with powder and this is your firing pin
right there
and it looks like a nerf football I was
going to say we stand with that we just
have velcro pads and we would throw them
at the game yeah well you would throw
this to the other side and when it hit
it would blow up so that was your early
Hand Grenade ages 7 and up with that one
yeah well age of ages 12 and over yeah
just to have enough and these are swim
goggles yes that they look exactly like
it they they fit you so well yeah
actually those the guys were born
using the cannons this was protect their
eyes moment powder cannon fire yeah so
that's that's all the the guys and
artillery these are all things related
to Civil War and actually one of the
famous generals in the Civil War was
James a Garfield okay
and he was so good at what he did that
Lincoln said I got a hippy in Congress I
need help bad so Garfield came back he
was a major general he gets in Congress
he helps pass the first 23 civil rights
laws that are passed for equality in
Congress he becomes a 20th president and
this happens to be a letter from and
it's kind of
I don't want to say this it's not what
you expect of a president but in this
letter and he's says here he's a
preacher and he I can't believe it would
call someone's wife that well yeah yeah
I can't really I can't I can't read this
at all I don't know how you can read
this he says he preached 19 times in a
revival meeting there were 34 editions
and he baptized 31 by Merson so here you
got a guy who is a guy we have know as a
president who was a revival preacher
well I mean we don't think about faith
with these guys that was a really big
part of their life but let me see how do
you juxtapose when people talk about
Abraham Lincoln and you know the belief
that a black man was worth 3/5 that of a
well I love you brought that up the best
answer to that is to go to black
commentators on the Constitution go to
Frederick Douglass because Frederick
Douglass escape from slavery he made it
to Boston he started speaking first in
New York for the New York abolitionist
society and in Boston wanted hiring
full-time and he was trained at the feet
of what are called radical abolitionists
Garrett and Smith and some of those guys
and they said you know we have a real
problem in America we have a pro-slavery
Constitution it's been flawed in the
beginning we need a new constitution so
this hardcore abolitionists thought the
Constitution is a flawed document he
said I believe that they were taught he
said but when I was hired full-time by
the by the Massachusetts abolitionist
decided to speak full time he said I
decided I better read it for myself he
said when I read the Constitution he
said I saw that in it there was not a
single pro-slavery clause it was
anti-slavery and everything well then
what do you do at three-fifths
three-fifths if you go back to the
debates in 1787 three-fifths the
southern states said we want to count
every black and the northern states said
count them but free them first they need
to be free cuz you're not representing
them you're using and so what happened
was they arrived at this compromise is
that okay every black you count you get
more pro-slavery representation in
Congress so they went back and forth
they said okay here's the deal we'll let
you count three-fifths of your blacks
and so that cut pro-slavery
representation by 40% in Congress there
was nothing about the worth of the
individuals it was about the
representation from them and so when
people hear that three the Constitution
says blacks are only worth three-fifths
for
Douglas said I checked it that's not
true that was an anti-slavery provision
to limit that and how long did that last
it's still in the Constitution that well
it was done away with the Civil Rights
amendments 13th 14th 15th amendment in
1865 through 1870 that's no longer an
issue so we got to it's pretty quickly
they they yeah and it was interesting
that when when they did that I mean back
in the founding era it was the
anti-slavery founding fathers who came
up with the three-fifths clause to put
less pro-slavery people in Congress does
that come with being so close to
taxation without representation as well
there because you won't represent him
that's right but you cannot represent
him and that's what the that's what the
North said and by the way this was a fun
debate they said you know you guys in
the south do you say that blacks are
your property and you're counting your
property to get more pro-slavery reps so
we're gonna count our horses and our
cows and our chairs and our rooms every
right now someone's good mad and say
you're comparing black slaves to horses
and cows no we're not they remove the
historical context no for example you
see this sometimes where when you are
fighting really bad enemies abroad for
example see sometimes you have to
partner form coalition's with the lesser
of even sometimes the historical context
is well why do we have a relationship
with Saudi Arabia Allah we're not really
happy yeah exactly we're not weren't big
fans as necessarily of Stalin the
three-fifths was a means to an end to
just make sure that they were weren't
being misrepresented right and well I
appreciate it I tried to lay that one up
and you handled it superbly so I got
another one for you here I'm distracted
by the hand grades what was this was
this was this in case you needed to get
rid of your leg and turn it into this
what that's right if you get shot right
there
I will promptly take your leg off for
you and I to be a good surgeon to
central oh yeah I would say so right now
I wonder what DNA would show if we
tested that for blood but at that point
in time probably not awaken if I yeah
may not have been may not have been if I
could not take your leg off and stop the
bleeding within a minute I could not be
a surgeon so I and you're gonna get no
it's a horrible incentive that's I want
it I want a surgeon to take as much care
as possible take your time doc no
because you get no painkillers and if I
don't do it in under a minute you will
bleed out and bleed to death so I have
to be able to do it take it off and stop
the bleed so this actually is to cut off
a leg this was used to cut off a leg oh
my god
I was joking no no this is for real this
is your amputation saw in the Civil War
children could see that and you see this
coming at you and you've got no no kind
of deadening no I mean there's nothing
no anesthesia so I'm watching there are
that because Abraham Lincoln's wife was
taking about opium yes there were there
was yeah she had a lot of depression
problems a lot of depression problem
okay so let me ask that that is
absolutely terrifying I thought no you
actually cutting off your leg imagine
that Gigi just think of how much more
intimate battle was back then one one of
the in Vicksburg Mississippi
there's about battlefield memorabilia
kind of stuff that's there and one of
them is is they would cut off your leg
they would give you one of the bullets
to bite and it's whether you get biting
the bullet and they have bullets there
they were bitten by guys the boat's
about that big and when it's over it's
about that big and it is as thin as
paper because just keep biting on it
these stupid people they were shaving
they had leather strokes why don't they
just bite on leather what would give him
give him a leg I don't know that they
bite the bullet and there are actually
there are actually pictures of word that
a surgeon was in the middle of sawing
off a guy's leg it's halfway through and
they all look up and smile for the
camera and he goes back to sawing again
and the guy who's getting his leg sawed
off is actually look at the cameras
smiling for the people it's a oh my do
you think maybe it started with one guy
bit the bullet to show how tough he was
and then no one else thought I can bite
the leather belt like well Dennis bit
the bullet so now I got to do it
otherwise I'm never gonna hear the end
of it from the guys that are gonna do a
movie about them with glory yeah Morgan
Freeman is never gonna let me live this
down no telling where it came from gosh
I see that stuff and I just a cringe
think what it was like to live back then
and 620,000 guys gave their lives once
out of the other a lot sacrificed their
lives to end slavery a lot sacrifice
their lives to defend the system they
didn't really understand a lot of
suddenly guys they weren't fighting for
slavery they're fighting custom north
invade that's important that's an
important tool in iation because I think
a lot of people where they say well we
see the Confederate flag as a symbol of
heritage and we don't see it the way you
see it I think a lot of people from the
south don't see it that way but like the
leader
when they had the opportunity to clarify
their position they made it very clear
that they wanted to leave because of
slavery let me ask you let me ask you
this
this is something we hear a lot about a
lot about Young Turks MSNBC CNN it's
sort of accepted as a truism the the
Southern Strategy
well yeah Abraham Lincoln was a
Republican and if you look back then
Republicans obviously they're the ones
about freeing the slaves and if you look
at even the Civil Rights Act but there
was there was a Southern Strategy where
it swapped what do you say that well it
certainly was not that way for the first
more than a century right I mean if I
take a piece like this this is a hit
card for the Klan this shows in a
lynchings a big deal for Atlanta so they
have given you now then of their mental
state when you really think yeah yes
thank you
63 names here that need to be taken care
of 63 names these are all Republican
members of the legislature there are 50
blacks there are 13 whites now people
say wait a minute they didn't Lynch
White's together there 4,800 lynchings
and the 4,800 lynchings that happened
with those 4,800 lynchings 1,300 were
white 3,500 black the lynchings were
Republicans now the deal was just about
Republicans why Republicans say you
couldn't Lynch anyway because some might
be Democrats but blacks that's a
different thing right so you could go at
it that way and so what you find is when
you look after what once the 13th and
14th amendment were past you could elect
blacks to office in the south and in
states like Louisiana states like South
Carolina Mississippi you had more blacks
in did whites so what happens is for
example the first 137 blacks elected in
Louisiana were all Republicans right the
first 41 blacks in Texas the first
hundred 90 blacks in South Carolina that
first 99 and Alabama 112 in Mississippi
cetera so it the the switching of
parties no blacks wore straw Republicans
at that point in time and they say well
you know that's let's started changing
in the 60s of southern strategy Strom
Thurmond aye Strom Thurmond was a
Democrat no question he ran against
Harry Truman because Harry Truman did
some really good civil rights stuff
helped desegregate the military he would
not count out to the Democrats in his
party that were racist so they ran a
Democrat against him Strom Thurmond the
dicks
crap party so strom thurmond runs as a
southern Democrat against and and you
know Harry Truman I mean he is from a
southern state in a border state he was
raised in racist atmosphere but he did
the right thing with helping civil
rights and so Strom Thurmond is a
Democrat well Strom Thurmond became a
Republican he sure did and became a
republic because he changed his
philosophy because he became the first
Senate Republican from the south to hire
blacks onto his staff as major positions
and so it's not Democrats that did that
it was a Republican who did he left the
Democrat Party because of their
positions so when they point to Strom
Thurmond you've also got to look at the
fact that he also changed his policy
positions and it was no longer he became
a blessed forest he became less racist
and actually he tried to break through
the barrier he had a lot of education a
lot of what you know I think we're gonna
do a whole installment because you have
so much here on black history so before
we but let me before we do that let me
here's what I say for those who say in
the South I say okay the let's let's
assume you're right let's assume that
Democrats switched to the Republican
Party I'm going to take any southern
state and in 70's 80's 90's you're going
to have a thousand people elected to
office every election you're gonna have
that your local people your County
people your others and it was called the
solid Democrat South for a reason
because Democrats not so I want you to
find me any 10 offices in the south
where the Democrats became Republicans
and got elected you just show me ten out
of a thousand nobody's shown me more
than two or three well you got Strom
Thurmond and you got David Duke and
David Duke but I went back to the
Democratic Party they can show me two or
three right show me if you're saying
that that the thing you got to show me a
majority otherwise your premise doesn't
hold up you can't even show me ten out
of a thousand so this is what people
repeat without thinking about it and
there's certainly not evidence enough to
prove that it was a shift what they call
the southern strategy so the Republican
Party is still the party of Lincoln yes
I don't think they know that because I
don't think they know what Lincoln bleed
and I don't think they knew what the
original platform this happens to be the
original Republican platform that's the
very first one there's only nine planks
in the platform seven on the nine deal
with civil rights equality making all
people equal equality and pay excetera
that's the original republican platform
and I'll bet you most Republicans have
no clue it is this is the second
in platform in 1860 seventeen planks
this is a third Republican platform
complex compares the Democrats and the
Republicans side-by-side this is the
first platform to call for a
constitutional amendment to abolish
slavery so I would say most Republicans
today don't know what Lincoln believed
although the platform's tell us what he
believed but no question that that
Lincoln was anti-slavery okay I guess I
was gonna say what I was going to ask
you what you believe the most common
misconception of the civil war was but I
think that we've addressed it in full it
seems to be that a lot of people don't
think it was actually about slavery and
of course we have more segments you can
just hit subscriber notifications on
YouTube let us know we'll probably come
back out here as well after the fourth
of July week to do more segments with
David Barton because my god this is I
don't want to touch anything going very
uncommon
I'm sweating it's like a library I keep
thinking I'm gonna get shush to a lady
who looks like an angry snail
yeah I don't know I'm not I just it's
going to spontaneously combust we have
the Civil War we have Second Amendment
First Amendment go enjoy those videos or
don't you don't have to that's the
wonder of the constant you don't have to
do anything do it